قدرت تجهات الحكوميه سعوديه عده من التبرع
عبر منشات مخالفه تدعي حصولها على الترخيص
مشدده على ان المشاركه فيها تورط صاحبها
وتعرضه للمسائله
رئاسه امن الدوله في السعوديه تقول بان
الاستجابه لدعوات جمع الاموال او المشاركه
فيها تعرض صاحبها للمسائله النيابه العامه
السعوديه تقول بانه يحضر استغلال تداعيات
العمل الانساني في دعوات لجمع اموال
التبرعات بقصد التمويه او اخفاء اموال غير
مشروعه وغسلها تحت غطاء العمل الخيري كما
تقتصر الاعمال الانسانيه على الجهات
الرسميه المختصه وزاره الداخليه السعوديه
تقول بان جمع التبرعات بدون ترخيص عامل
مخالف للانظمه ومنها نظام مكافحه الارهاب
وتمويله
وزاره التجاره السعوديه حذرت ايضا من
التعامل مع منشات تزعم ترخيصها وتدعو
للتبرع وجمع الاموال مقابل حفر ابار
المياه في الخارج مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه قال نحن الجهه الوحيده التي تتولى
تسليم اي تبرعات اغاثيه او خيريه او
انسانيه سواء كان مصدرها حكوميا او اهليا
لايصالها الى محتاجها في الاستوديو ينضم
الينا المحامي والمستشار القانون الدكتور
اسامه القحطاني دكتور اسامه حياك الله
تتجدد التحذيرات مره اخرى من كثير من
الجهات من التبرع لجهات مجهوله ايضا
التي تدعي
المساهمه في العمل الخيري لمن لما نشوف
هذه التحذيرات التي تتجدد كل فتره يعني
هذا مدى يعني اولا تعني بانه زياده هذه
العمليات عمليات النصب والاحتاج والاحتيال
والتبرعات ايضا لهذه الجهه
مرتبط ايضا بالفتره التي نعيشها حاليا نحن
في رمضان تعرف الناس تكون مقبله على فعل
الخير
والبحث عن اوجه الانفاق في الخير والى
اخره فربما كان مرتبط بهذا الجانب اكثر
والحقيقه ان المشكله هنا هي ليست في في
هناك
عقوبات رادعه كثيره جدا هناك نظام قوي
هناك هناك مراقبه عاليه ولكن المشكله في
وعي الناس عندما شخص يقوم بالتبرع لاي شخص
لشخص لا يعرفه او قد يعرفه لكن لا يعرف
اين يتصرف بهذه الاموال هنا مشكله كبيره
جدا يتعرض الكثير من الناس لعدد من من
الاشكاليات القانونيه وربما يتعرض للسجن
او الغرامه الكبيره
وممكن الت اليها هذه الاموال
عندما جزء منها هناك من خلال التاريخ
القريب هناك كثير من هذه التبرعات ذهبت
لارهاب مثلا
او ذهبت لغسيل اموال وما الى ذلك او حتى
ربما الى فساد شخصي مثلا الى استيلاء على
هذه الاموال والى اخره وهناك قصص كثير جدا
وناس بريئون ليس لهم اي علاقه الا يعني في
قصص احداها مثلا شخص اعرفه جيدا بسبب
علاقه قرابه مع شخص تبرع بمبلغ وفي
النهايه قال هو ايضا الى سجل لان ذهبت
مباشره الى اعمال ارهابيه في فترات اللي
كانت في ارهاب لدينا
فلماذا يعرض الانسان نفسه لمثل هذه
المسؤوليه الكبيره
وهناك اوجه
مرخصه ورسميه يمكنك من خلالها تقديم العون
المباشر او من خلال معرفتك الشخصيه لماذا
لا تتبرع الا من خلال شخص ياخذ منطبق حتى
على الجهه الخارجيه التبرعات للابار وبناء
الابار والاحتيال اللي يحصل فيها يعني
طبعا التبرع للجهه الخارجيه هنا هنا خطوره
لانه المنع من الجمع ايضا يحضر اي جمع
لاعمال خارج المملكه الا من خلال جهه
رسميه مرخصه وتحتاج ايضا لترخيص اخر اذا
كانت تبرع لشيء خارج المملكه
وهناك جهات كثيره مرخصه لدى لدينا في سواء
في المملكه او حتى على المستوى الخليج
وغيره
لسنا بحاجه لان نبحث عن اشخاص ربما بكلمات
او بخطبه عاطفيه يستدر عواطف الناس من
خلالها ويذكر
التبرع للجهات الخارجيه دكتور اسامه يعني
وخاصه مساله الابار يعني يجيك واحد مثلا
يعطيك بير باسمك اليوم يتغير بيصير باسم
ثاني يعني التبرع لهذه الجهات ايضا وش
مخاطرها وتبعاتها اللي ممكن تعرض هذا
المتبرع
للمخاطرها كبيره جدا يعني من في مثل هذا
النوع اللي تحدثت عن الخالدي اللي هو حفر
الابار على سبيل المثال هذه من الاشياء
التي لا يمكن كانت تراك ما تستطيع ان
تتتبع اين ذهب المال حفر بئر في اي مكان
العالم قد يكون محفور قديما قد يكون حفر
شخص اخر
ممكن هذه الصوره تتوزع مع اكثر من شخص
بامكان يعني لا يوجد اليه للتحقق الا من
خلال جهه رسميه
وبالتجربه هناك الكثير من الاموال التي تم
التصرف فيها بهذا الشكل وهي في الحقيقه لم
تنفذ على ارض الواقع او انه اسيء
استغلالها
وهي قصص كثيره جدا يعني وايضا هناك وسائل
رسميه تستطيع ان تتبرع من خلالها يعني او
ان تذهب بنفسك يا اخي ولكن ان تعطي هذه
الاموال لاشخاص قد لا تكون معرفتك بهم
كافيه
لدرجه ان ان تعرض نفسك ايضا للمخاطره بدلا
من البحث عن الخير ان تعرض نفسك ايضا
للمخاطره انها قد تذهب الى ارهاب او الى
شخص لديه اشياء اعمال مشبوهه من غسل اموال
او اي امر مشابه او حتى استغلال وهذا حصل
انه هناك جمعيات حتى كثيره اغلقت بسبب
وجود اما اعمال ارتبطت باعمال مشوبه
بالارهاب او ايضا الاستغلال والتصرف في
هذه الاموال من قبل هؤلاء الذين يجمعون
الاموال هذول الناس اللي يتبرعوا الدكتور
اسامه التقيت فيهم ببعضهم يعني اكيد ليش
الاصرار مثلا على انهم يذهبوا الى هذه
الجهات مع انه في جهات مضمونه ومامونه
[موسيقى]
ويحذر حتى من اكثر من الجهات ليش وهما ناس
حتى واعيين وفاهمين وعارفين فبالتالي ليش
الاصرار على الذهاب الى هذه الجهه عدم
ثقافه مثلا في الجهه الاخرى الحكوميه ولا
ايش بالضبط لا اعتقد اتصور يعني هي
الظاهره ليست فقط في المملكه مثلا او في
الخليج هي ظاهره في اماكن كثيره من العالم
وان كانت تكثر لدينا بسبب ان الناس يعني
يتوارثون ما يسمى بالكرم ومساعده الاخرين
ومناصرتهم ولكن المشكله في الاليه التي
يستخدمونها يعني هم لا يلجاون لهؤلاء بسبب
عدم وجود غيرهم وانما في الحقيقه لسهوله
او كثره تواصل هؤلاء اما مثلا عبر الشوارع
مثلا او الاماكن العامه او من خلال
المساجد والناس دائما محبه للخير وكذا
فياتي شخص ويؤثر فيهم بموعظه وقصص والناس
بطبعهم عاطفيين ولذلك نعول دائما وان كان
هناك عقوبات رادعه الا اننا نعوض دائما
على الوعي اذا كان هناك وعي لماذا تعطي
اموالك لشخص لا تعرفه او قد تعرفه لكن لا
تعرف كيف يتصرف بها ولا توجد اليه لرقابه
هذا المال كيف ذهب واين صرف وعلى منصرف
الى اخره فلماذا تضع نفسك في مثل هذا
الامر اما ان تقوم العمل بالعمل بنفسك او
ان تذهب من خلال المؤسسات الرسميه اشكرك
بشكر جزيلا شكرا وسام القحطاني المحامي
والمستشار القانوني شكرا لك الله يحفظك